what is 5g and
what is something that probably
everybody thinks they know but
they have one probably one of the
biggest innovations since the invention
of the internet really the explosion
of the industrial internet the problem
with tick tock is really about
what you can do with people's data who
owns your data
it's actually china it's censorship it's
control of your population
we don't even have a telecommunications
manufacturer left in this country
so we're not leading anything can we
adapt
to the world that we created that has
basically been weaponized against us
reality is we were asleep at the wheel
we're drinking kool-aid
[Music]
so welcome to another episode of
generally speaking today we have john
trobaugh
co-ceo of q networks and a silicon
valley veteran we're going to ask him
about technology 5g
and a whole bunch of other things so
john thanks for joining
generally speaking nice to see you again
ron
so uh and and this time it works so uh
can you tell us a little bit about
yourself
you were talking before when we tried
this the first time a little bit about
your
uh your three prong career so yeah as i
was saying earlier i've had uh
probably three distinct careers i think
that the first part of my career was in
the
more traditional telecom operator space
back before we invented
digital wireless or the mobile internet
and then the next phase of my career i
spent about
20 plus years in silicon valley as a
software ceo
and uh got to know the valley and got to
see the the rise of the
the dot-com era and the downturn and
actually even lived through the
the mortgage meltdown so uh got that
roller coaster
and then most recently i've spent my
time working at the intersection of uh
government and technology with the
private sector and how do we get
private technologists uh more engaged
with government to help push forward
some of these uh
technology challenges uh that we have
so so that's where i met you and uh when
i was in the pentagon and you were
working in the white house and you were
a prestigious
uh presidential innovation fellow so can
you
uh can you tell us what a presidential
innovation fellow is and how you ended
up
um you know going from i don't know
you're on your couch to uh
to the to the white house that's a good
story yeah
as a an obama baby as i'm sometimes
referred to as well
which but i'm one of the few
presidential fellows who worked
across both administrations so i do have
that distinction but
but yeah during my uh i was literally
sitting on the couch in silicon valley
and
had just uh got done on a project with
boeing and we exited a company and
was watching the news and i see
president signs the executive order
creating
presidential innovation fellows and i
was sitting there drinking a scotch and
had my ipad next to me i said well that
sounds kind of cool and
i just sent a cold call email to the
white house
and they called me back and then when
they called me back at first i thought
it was a joke and i didn't call them
back
and then the second the second time they
called they said well maybe it really is
the white house i answered
and that's how i wound up uh you know
spending a
couple years in washington dc going back
and forth to dc and silicon valley and
and getting plugged into uh government
and trying to bring commercial
technologists uh
into department of defense in particular
so so what was your
the i think the biggest uh shock that
you had coming into government
what was it i mean what how is it
different than you know working in the
private sector
well i could state the obvious you know
the uh the the paperwork
and uh you know these the slowness and
decision making
but uh i think probably the real shock
for me was
uh was the hours that people
really work more normalized
so you know eight to five lifes if you
will as opposed to uh
maybe what i was more accustomed to
which is the uh hair on fire
you know gotta beat the the next closest
tech company who's breathing down your
neck
uh you know because your venture
capitalists are are sitting on top
you know type of uh environment of the
valley so so they're very very different
environments both of them with their
their pros and cons though
so so your goal or your task was to
bring
some silicon valley uh expertise to
government
how did that go and uh and was it
easy to recruit people to come and do
that
well how did it go what i found is that
you could come up with some really cool
ideas and you know we worked on a
project called cloud.gov and really
trying to look at how do you
how do you bridge uh small business uh
companies
into government so the government could
actually purchase their products and
services and so we built a
cloud.gov portal and you could go out
and buy all these different
apps and services that the commercial
world has to offer
but then when we got to the next phase
which is okay now we got to go market it
and tell everybody inside of government
that we built this
project then they came down well you
actually can't spend any money to do
that
so that was uh that was like wait wait
learning experience
wait what you can't spend money no we
couldn't spend
we could not spend marketing dollars to
go out and promote and make government
aware that we had gone and built this
portal
that they had asked us to to to bridge
small
business into government and to allow
government to
to more rapidly acquire you know uh or
procure
you know small business products and
services and so
that was a learning experience and then
after that
then i focused you know obviously you
know you and i where we cross paths
trying to figure out what the
national security council is you know
how does it designate how do we
how do we bring private industry
technologists uh
into the defense side and i think uh
we've done a real good job
of of deploying presidential innovation
fellows across the federal government
you know the story is your presidential
fellows started because of the uh
the health care website that had gone
down and and how the white house had
reached out to silicon valley to help
and it just kind of snowballed from
there but uh
we hadn't yet crossed the the uh
uh river if you will and said okay let's
go work with the pentagon and
let's go see if we can figure out how to
bring technologists into the pentagon
to also help dod with technology
challenges and bringing
you know cots products or commercial
services into dod
so and that's where you and i met and
um and that is where um consequently
the um the infamous diux paper
comes from that uh that bringing silicon
valley into the defense department so
can you do you remember the story can
you tell the story of how that came
together and it and it ultimately led to
uh the current leadership in diu yeah
well you know we
were uh i think you know you and i were
looking at uh
trying to figure out how to do something
with uh with the new uh
office that you were standing up in
china or looking at china inside of dod
and
you know there's an opportunity to uh
educate people on
who the largest investor in silicon
valley is and most people
you know believe historically uh they're
always surprised to think well it's
intel
right uh which historically has been
true but it's actually
you know uh china yes
chinese communist party the chinese
communist party has
access to u.s technology and know-how
and silicon valley
faster than you know our own uh our own
government does and so
yeah so we uh you know looked to
collaborate on that paper and at the
same time
uh mike brown from uh symantec was
you know moving on from from his
position and uh
he's another one that i had uh just
picked up the phone and reached out to
and said hey you want to want to get
back and
something kind of interesting over here
and we uh we mixed a good class of
kool-aid
and you and i both didn't we were able
to pull mike in and get him to write
that paper
and work on it with some colleagues and
and really run around and start
educating the hill on
you know what a uh uh who is the real
largest investor in silicon valley and
so and then today he's
since gone on to turn that into uh he he
loves gov tech so much that he he
decided to stay in the uh
and he's running eods yeah i know dod's
version of venture capital right and so
he's
still uh uh he's still in it today and i
guess we can say that's our claim to
fame is that we're both out but
you know we talked him he's still in
well i mean i think the the the big so
what of that that people don't realize
is you know from that small beginnings
from you picking up the phone
and you know calling the white house to
um where we're at today that was the
beginning
that diux report that mike wrote
you know that we we collectively you and
i work together to bring mike into
government that diux report
is the genesis essentially of
what we would get eventually get in
government called the section 301 report
the section 301 investigation that the
u.s trade representative did
that all tariffs on china are basic that
basically come from so that
started it started with that diux report
um that that we worked on so you know
part of the the the goal of that was to
show that you know this progression of
from a very humble you know start from
you're
picking up the phone and and uh and
calling the white house and
and coming on board and we met and i'm
trying to figure out china
and you have the experience and the
connections to
to allow that to happen really
eventually led to
you know probably one of the most
consequential reversals in trade policy
in u.s history and that that that's just
one of the many things that uh
that you know i think we've been around
but probably the most important thing
that i see today and that that you're
currently working on
uh as co-ceo of q networks is the is a
5g network so
what is 5g and you know
what in your mind is something that that
that probably everybody thinks they know
but they have wrong
yeah what is 5g i mean gosh you uh
don't don't don't you see it when you
turn on your phone it says 5g
or you watch the tv commercials coming
through a town near you
right there's so much noise out there in
you know
hand waving and misrepresentation on on
5g and where it is but
but ultimately you know all that being
aside from a pure technology perspective
i look at 5g as being
probably one of the biggest uh
innovations since the
the invention of the internet and i say
that just simplistically because it's
where
you know wire line connectivity and
wireless tech connectivity start to to
collide and we start to have ubiquity
between you know speeds and and access
and is one you know uh major aspect of
5g but it's also
you know uh will enable a new generation
of services as well and the really the
the explosion
of the industrial internet and we talk a
lot today you know everyone everyone
wants to associate wireless with being
about
voice and i can gain faster or
video and the reality is that's the real
value of 5g is enabling the industrial
internet and it's really how do we
to me it's it's the it's the foundation
for how it is we're going to move
forward in the reindustrialization of
this country it's
you know if we can roll out 5g and we
can
do it you know in a constructive way we
can create a next generation of
manufacturing jobs
and get back to where we used to be
which would be technical thought leaders
and telecommunications
and and we've lost that uh is the
reality and that's something americans
don't want to believe
but the data all speaks the truth and
but 5g
you know is a is a to me is a major
underpinning
on our future economic viability as a
nation
i just don't think i think we keep
thinking of it in terms of i'm going to
watch faster movies
and who gives a damn we we gotta if we
don't get back to reindustralizing the
nation and using you know using this uh
the industrial internet to be the
underpinning of that we got bigger
problems
so there's this big thing going on now
in government called tick tock
and and uh of course you and i have
talked about tick tock quite a big
brand in my house right it's banned in
your house but
you know i i think one of the things
that people don't understand is that the
problem with tick tock is really about
the
problem of what you can do today
with people's data so you can literally
understand the personality
the interactions the relationships
nearly just about
everything that you want about a person
using the data collected by their
smartphone
but then when you build that into a
smart city
you literally have everything about the
person
now we typically don't think about the
problems that causes but
as you and i have talked about the
ability to
influence you to buy a pair of shoes
that amazon leverages with their
data empire and algorithms and and
machine learning and artificial
intelligence
can also be used to affect your
political orientation your
your cultural your social uh orientation
and really can be used as we know to
undermine
our political system so you know
you know talk talk us through kind of
what the
data security problems are in 5g because
i think that's where um you know people
have heard this a faster smartphone but
okay
what's all that what's going who has
access to this data
that you know the tech companies are
creating
yeah you're right that's a that's even a
you know a bigger picture description of
you know what 5g does right is that 5g
creates uh you know let's call it
hypothetically 10x the amount of data
that we we see today
and even at a more at a more granular
level and if you believe
as as many do and i think china's even
come out and said this right the
the data is the gold of the or the oil
of the next generation
then you gotta gotta scratch your head
and go in the u.s it's like well
what the hell are we doing about it
right we're and so when you look at
things like for me when i look at things
like tick tock i'm like okay well why
don't we just put a
put a uh you know a beacon in
everybody's hand and let them walk
around and they can call in and collect
you know
the other nation states can collect as
much information as they want on on
individual us citizens or or their
surroundings as they need
and uh and tick tock i think is just the
poster child for
where an explosive app or service can
really
enable that that type of potential you
know
government state sponsored you know
access to to u.s citizens which is
you know really unheard of because we
don't as
american citizens we don't really think
about the about uh you know data
and uh the importance you know of data
but i think specific to your question
you know when you think about 5g then
you go okay well 5g
we've always also had this point of view
that uh that well
networks are secure because we trust our
our north american you know
wireless operators if we don't trust
them you know who do we trust
right and uh and the reality is that
historically
and you go uh you know through all the
g's up through 4g
it's primarily been driven by a lot of
uh
u.s influence or even directly by the
u.s where we've
always been leaders in the
telecommunications and the last hundred
years the u.s
has led the telecommunications industry
you look at it today and you go into 5g
we don't even have a telecommunications
manufacturer left in this country
so we're not leading anything so what
we're doing is buying other people's
products and services and putting it
into our networks
and then telling us citizens trust it's
okay
don't worry i bought it in china but you
can trust it so i mean
i think it's uh you know in that in and
of itself
exposes a lot of data risk you get into
all the issues whether it's you know
man in the middle and how people are
snooping on snooping on you
or you get into uh you know who owns
your data
right or you know do you trust your data
being you know unencrypted
or uh it raises a lot of questions and i
think there's
a lot of data privacy issues that come
with 5g which we're just not even really
talking about because we don't
understand
that it's really about data and you know
let's let's win the battlefield oil of
the next generation
and let's let that drive our our
economic policy decisions and then also
drive what we should be doing
from a technology level we build out
networks
so so one of the things that government
has said
is that if we just get rid of huawei in
in north america then everything's fine
so
so is huawei the only problem because
um you know what i understand is that
when you
bring all these companies together you
know i'm an air force guy you're an
industry guy but when you bring
huawei and ericsson and samsung and and
nokia together aren't aren't they
building
basically a a a um
what's the word i'm looking here for a
common network our common architecture
uh at least in terms of the way they
look at the technology that underpins 5g
yeah i think you're probably uh alluding
to a bit the
the standards right the interoperability
of the standards and
this idea that uh if we if we don't
uh uh by huawei then hey everything's
great right we're gonna use
erickson or we're gonna use uh china
right or
china i mean nokia who's you know uh has
a lot of uh
you know business in in subsidiaries in
china as well
but the real issue is that you know then
you go look at and say okay well who
does
who designed the global standard right
is remember as i said is that the us
designed in or the west
we've really influenced the first four
generations we sure as held infinity
influenced the fifth
i mean you go look at the the number of
patents and who owns the most potent 5g
it's no one in the u.s you got qualcomm
up there
maybe you got intel up there but who
else
right i mean 5g the standard the global
standard is
is is driven by a lot of
chinese companies and you know that's
uh they've been very aggressive in you
know their global standards
participation
with uh uh an eye towards how they
believe
the network should be designed and built
out and
uh i think from it from a u.s
perspective had we been
a lot more active and you know i'm sure
i could walk you know be
blasphemy if i were talking to a carrier
but since i sometimes the ceo of a
private carrier that's
you know looking at this issue going no
we got it wrong you know i'm gonna say
it but
reality is we were asleep at the wheel
and uh you know we just assumed that the
the the telecommunications
infrastructure providers that we buy
product from
uh were taken into consideration
you know our democratic values around
privacy and other things when they're
thinking about the management of data
and how to securitize that
in a world where data is going to
completely explode
and you're going to have ubiquity
between the internet and the wireless
internet
and we know still we still when we still
this day we keep talking 5g it's like
well i'm not faster netflix
right people they do not understand the
game that we are really playing on a
global level
with this uh this this data this data
war if you will
and uh the importance of 5g is the
underpinning for that and how we
as the nation we just can't lose right
and uh
right now everyone says uh we're
building out 5g and like you know if you
believe the tv commercials hell it's
coming to a city near me right so so you
brought that up in the beginning
so what is it what is the state of play
with the neps the network equipment
providers
uh in north america just say for
cbrs radio since cbrs is in the mid-band
because right they're the att is
building
5g t-mobile
verizon they're all building 5g so you
should be able to get easily get a
a cbrs band radio in in north america in
5g
right yeah no i think you're you know
it's a duopoly i mean the reality is
that the ecosystem does what the
carriers tell them to do and though
so when you have new new new entrants
such as what we're doing at queue and
you're looking at how
how do you build out a securitized
network that enables end users to
control their data
to manage the privacy and the use of
their own data and information
i pick up the phone and i call you know
any of the different
radio access network providers and say
hey i want to buy
cbrs radios and you know their their
response is
well you know once we give it to a t or
verizon then you can come back and buy
it
and so they're they don't do anything
they don't build them it's all bespoke
right and it's uh based on if they're
not ordering the radios
they're they're not available they're
not there so so the truth of the matter
is they're not building 5g i mean that's
that's that i think that's the point
that you're trying to make is that
they're saying they are but they're but
they're really not well you know
cbs radios are not there for yeah
they're just not available
right available so so
when you um when you think about silicon
valley
and and everybody thinks of silicon
is synonymous with technology so you
alluded to something
that i think is very important and that
is that
you know we've lost the bubble we've
lost a lead on technology so
you know in reality silicon valley is no
longer about technology
it's more about you know how do you you
know create this
next unicorn based on
getting to market faster with your idea
but
in in all reality the technology is not
that
exquisite it's basically some new way
or new application or new use of
existing technology
that you try to rush to market so
there's not a lot of actual
invention going on other than in
business models
would you agree with that statement yeah
i think that i think the focus is on
business model creativity uh new
algorithm development for
harvesting of data and uh
you know new creative ways to to
uh to generate usage data
but and and i think of that being more
at the application
you know layer if you will but if you go
down into uh
you know you say well who builds the
middleware who builds the
the the next generation infrastructure
uh
if you will uh there's not you know uh
they're not big dollars pouring into
that it's it's
typically viewed as uh you know i don't
want to do that i mean look you look at
the way software's even developed today
and this just take even at the
the the service or the application layer
you take something like
you know a github and the analogy i like
to use it's like you know
knowing how to frame a house and know
why studs are six
you know 12 inches on center and and how
it is you
you frame out that wall is very
different than standing up the prefab
wall you know all ready to go and saying
well now i know how to build a home
right the guy the the the company that
knows why why the studs are 12 inches on
center is a very different company
than one that just slaps four walls
together and i think we've lost
and it gets back to almost in in many
ways to i look at is this bleed over
where we talk about the loss of
manufacturing in this country
i would also argue that we are losing
that that same mindset has bled over
in technology and software development
as well because we we're stopped we've
stopped building
the underlying pillars or the foundation
that enable the services that we want to
build
right and i think that's uh you know you
look at
look you go look at carriers today you
go look at you know the return on
capital
you know that they deliver versus a
google or facebook or the others
and if you're an investment banker it's
like well where are you going to put
your money you're going to go invest
into infrastructure or are you going to
go
keep enabling you know new apps and
services and go develop a new algorithm
so so we're we're not uh
we're not aligned there and i think you
know and what's what i also remind
people of which they
forget is that silicon valley was
actually started by
by the defense industry and uh
you know most people in silicon valley
don't even know
that this government in the defense
industry
has started silicon valley and right now
if you you were to run up and down sand
hill road
and say hey i got a tech start up and
it's awesome and we're going to sell to
the department of defense and government
they would uh you probably wouldn't even
get a meeting so
is the sad truth that's frightening
because i think the time that you're
talking about we were spending almost
two percent of gross domestic product
here in the united states on science and
technology
space race the cold war we were
investing
you know billions of dollars of
government money into
you know basic science research which we
don't do anymore you know
apple you know took advantage of a lot
of those investments that government
government had made and companies like
bell labs that had done
research for the united states on behalf
of the department of defense
that basically had this technology
sitting around and and a lot of silicon
valley was built on the back of that
and then what happened was we stopped we
just stopped investing
as a country in that and then what we
what we've done is we've been living off
the fat of that
for for decades now and we built
something amazing
but the problem is you know as we talk
about with tick tock
this amazing thing we we built actually
is
is best applied in a system that allows
you to control people
and you know i just had we just talked
to rand waltzman
uh in a prior episode and he's a master
of disinformation and he talks about
how the chinese have used crowd sourcing
to do crowd control which is something
that i think we would say
we are absolutely horrified by it's it's
censorship
it's control of your population but the
chinese communist party
has adapted the tools and the
technologies and the business models of
silicon valley
and then applied it not only to
oppressing their own people
but now they're you know essentially
influencing
our own uh population through
applications like tick tock through
businesses like uh alibaba and and
certainly
through the chinese communist party
basically putting pressure on u.s
companies
to censor their own employees for for
working
yeah no no disagreement i mean it's
uh uh
they've done it you know there's a good
job of extending that
that that control model via commercial
apps and services into
to other nation states and uh you know
it it would be like saying you know if
the us government were to
you know collect all the data from you
know
from the fangs here in the us and then
use that and harvest that data for
understanding
all the different nations that you know
those private u.s
companies or those public u.s companies
did business uh in
and and that's that goes against our our
values and our principles for democracy
and what
but uh you know the reality is that not
everybody else is playing
playing by the same rules and we don't
recognize that
and you know our views and of uh
you know you mentioned we're living off
the fat is one issue but i also think
that we
may have our head in the sand a little
bit on the fact that you know democracy
as we know it is
is really under under threat it's you
know some of some of the
underlying you know pillars of what
forms our views of what democracy are
are
changing very dramatically in front of
us because of technology
and we haven't yet adapted at a at a law
maker level as to what that means
look i i started this story when i was
you know
uh i won't say what company was the ceo
of a company in the valley
and we'd have uh politicians would come
through to to see what we were doing
and i would have to spend a half day you
know explaining our technology and what
we did and we did advanced
big data analytics and inevitably i
never got the congressman or you know
the sitting
elected official you'd always get some
20-something who at least understood how
to log in to facebook
or instagram or use some of those
services so then they could try to
interpret
what we were doing and then report that
up to lawmakers i think i think
even at a law maker level our
understanding of technology
and the implications of technology or in
how to formulate effective policy to
protect our democracy and further our
our economic agendas uh is uh is very
limited
yeah and so just uh for for the
audience out there fangs facebook amazon
apple netflix and google it's really
you know from the time the iphone was uh
came into view in 2007
over 10 years they they moved from being
nowhere to being now
25 of the standard poor um
uh index and and that means they have
huge outsized
uh control over the global information
economy not but not only that
you know they are really the targets
that the chinese communist party goes
after so baidu
uh is essentially google alibaba is
essentially amazon and tencent is
facebook and so their goal is
essentially
to take baidu alibaba and 10 cent and
through dominating the 5g platform
and being able to be the first to bring
those apps and services and business
models to market
to then use that to pole vault over the
top of the thing so you just
talked about how dangerous it would be
if the u.s
you know basically use the data that the
fangs collect and their
and their ability to mine that data for
information and
and create influential algorithms but
that's exactly what the chinese are
doing
and the bats baidu alibaba and tencent
have those same technologies except they
are controlled by
an authoritarian regime that essentially
wants to use that data for exactly those
things so
i mean this we're on the precipice of
you know a transformational
time in in not only geopolitics but only
but also in preserving our republic so
we're close to the 250 years where
most republics um essentially
disintegrate so the
the question i think that's so important
that you're alluding to is
can we adapt to the world that we
created
that has basically been weaponized
against us and this is
this is where i think you know both you
and i
have been focused on for you know the
last three years
and i think it's going to take you know
another 10
to really determine whether or not the
us
survives as a democracy how many
democracies
actually can you know make the
transition from understanding how to
protect their sovereignty
and independence in the physical world
or as our as you say the energy or the
oil
of the 21st century being data you know
can we
can we can we manage to transition and
protect ourselves
in the same way that we protected the
united states you know
in the in world war one and world war ii
in the cold war
but using different tools that really
have nothing to do with bombs and
bullets
you know it's it's can we um deal with
the fact
that as kaifu lee says and kaifu lee is
the leading
artificial intelligence thinker in china
you know they intend and are on the way
to becoming the saudi arabia of data
what does that mean for us
when they can take all of that data
which means theirs and ours
and then put it in algorithms that
really allow them to
pull the levers behind the scenes in
ways that we're not even we don't even
perceive
it's happening right now in our own you
know run up to a 2020 campaign
something that i'm completely um you
know terrified by because i think that
we're
we're not in position to actually defend
ourselves from it
no i don't i don't disagree with you it
is uh
the the 250-year republic you know was a
interesting combat and
yeah i sometimes wonder are we uh you
know you know
rome seems to have a a lot of analogy
right
you know when i think of it in in that
way but
but we did invent a lot of these tools
and services and if we can get back and
and this is where to me when we talk
about
re when i i mentioned
reindustrialization earlier to me it's
not just
you know bringing it's not bringing back
manufacturing the way manufacturing used
to be
it's it's also bringing back our
ingenuity and our technological
innovation
on how manufacturing you know should
look in the future right i mean look at
look at tesla and look at elon musk and
you know some of the the
factories out and uh that they're you
know factory the future that they're
are working on as a is a model that you
know will still creates jobs
still creates jobs and you know how you
know higher skilled jobs but
but it's a great example of where the
two worlds are are kind of coming
together and i think that also has to
happen in
in silicon valley as well is that it's
okay to get back to building
infrastructure i look at it as simply
simplistically as you know having been
in the software world we used to build
you know a lot of infrastructures that
you're you're designing and thinking of
the innovation infrastructure running
eye towards the services
that you want to enable in the future
but if you're not designing and building
the infrastructure
for what it is you want to enable in the
future you're just
sitting back waiting for someone to tell
you what it is they did
and that gets back to just sitting back
waiting for
you know whether it's china or someone
else to say hey tell us what the
tell us about that next wave of
infrastructure is going to be like so i
can start thinking about
creative business model and more
algorithms that does not push forward
our the economic interest interests of
you know of the country as a whole right
or the labor market
for the country as a whole and i think
technologists have
far more you know influence over
uh you know the infrastructure and
you know contribution to the
reindustrialization of the country than
they realize i think we can we tend to
think of it
as being you know i'm trying to just say
that you know a manufacturing plant
who's a cabinet maker
you know in pennsylvania or something
which you know a lot of great people who
are losing their jobs and
but it i think it it to me it bleeds
over into the technology as well and i
think when
when we can start to bridge the gap
between
uh those two uh uh
you know industries or our points of
view if you will
then then the us will have a chance but
right now
uh we're getting our butts handed to us
and we just don't want to admit it
because we
all feel like our 401ks are doing well
and stock markets up
but you know go peel back the stock
market and say well if i go take out
the fangs out of the stock market is the
market really way up the way it seems
i i think we're just we're drinking
kool-aid
yeah yeah you know where i i just read a
book and
and i know i i talked to you about it's
called the kill chain
uh written by christian bros and it
talks about that the fact that these
tools that you were working on in
silicon valley
actually never made their way into the
department of defense so this ability to
do
collaboration at the speed of light and
apply that on the battlefield
you just never made it there and it's
still not there today in fact
you know we we have these stove pipe
communication systems
we have these very archaic ways
of working and collaborating on the
battlefield that don't represent
you know modern tools that you know
business is using today and so
what he what what what christian talks
about is how do we bring that
into the modern battlefield to make us
you know better and more efficient and
killing
and and the reality is that we as we've
been talking about
it's not about applying force on the
battlefield anymore
if you can basically undermine you know
john troubas kids and make them think
that communism is better than democracy
because essentially
that's what the chinese communist
party's goal is is not to
fight with the united states is to
slowly erode
our own you know trust and
faith in the principles and values that
underpin the society that's it
you know the idea that you know war is
politics by other means
or rather politics is war by other means
is is what the chinese communist party
is after so
you know this is in my mind uh why
i left the military because i saw that
the battlefield had shifted it
shifted into our communities into our
cities
and into our our very homes and
something that we need to get after and
i think
you know what you have been doing and
what you have committed your life to do
i think is incredibly valuable
in that fight so you know i worse i wore
a flight suit
you were you wear a pullover and
flip-flops
you know i would say that the the
uniform of the modern warrior
is a pull over and and flip-flops and uh
and you know so i want to say i want to
thank you for your service
um and i want to thank you for your time
thank you for coming on generally
speaking
this has been you know incredibly
enlightening and and i always enjoy
talking to you so thanks
thanks john for coming on and uh and we
will have you on again
appreciate it rob we'll keep up the good
fight and uh hopefully we're both
looking back 10 years from now going
man we were right we pivoted at the
right time we made it
so we made it